a man shot trying to force his way into
a Washington DC TV station is
hospitalized in stable condition at this
hour
surveillance video from the Fox station
shows 38 year old George Odom's kicking
his way into the lobby before
encountering two security officers
Jeffery gazes outside the TV station
with new details about this violent
encounter Jeff good morning good morning
it is business as usual inside the TV
station this morning but on the outside
you can see behind me there's plywood
covering some of the doors and that's
where the suspect tried to push his way
in he's been charged with one count of
burglary as police continue to
investigate what is a bizarre incident
police say it unfolded at about 3 p.m.
yesterday afternoon
Odom's they say kicked in two sets of
glass doors on his way into the Fox
television station he then went into the
station's Lobby where he was confronted
by two female security guards station
employees say both guards stole the
suspect to back up but when he refused
he was pepper sprayed and then shot once
in the chest police say Owens was not
armed and then he was conscious when he
was taken to the hospital now the
suspect has a history with some of the
employees here at Fox 5 who say that he
is someone who regularly contacts staff
with bizarre messages and conspiracy
theories and by the way we did a search
of court records and found that he has a
murder charge in 2002 in his past but
that case was later dropped now we
talked to DC police sources who say that
they believe Odin's has a history of
mental illness but they're still trying
to figure out what sparked this incident
John thank you thank you Jeff